Now, before I had the honor
as a playwright to make it to Broadway,
which also opened the door for me
to work in TV and film,
like everybody, I had a dream growing up.
Now, before I tell you
what that dream was,
you have to promise not to laugh.
(Laughter)
You're going to laugh? Promise?
Alright.
When I was growing up,
I wanted to be ...
a superhero.
See, I wanted to be
what I saw so vibrantly
on the pages of my Marvel
and DC comic books.
I actually used to sit on a stoop
in the projects with my godbrother Johnny,
and we would create our own stories,
writing and drawing them all.
Now I have to confess,
years before Miles Morales,
we actually made
the first Black Spider-Man.
(Laughter)
Two of them. What can I say?
We was from Queens.
(Laughter)
Now, as we know, there's always
a moment in a superhero's life
where they realize
that they have superpowers.
Now mine was revealed to me
by my arch nemesis,
my eighth grade English teacher --
(Laughter)
after he gave the class
an assignment to write a poem.
What happened after I did that
would forever change
the course of my life.
Because when I turned in that assignment,
the poem was so good,
my teacher actually thought
I plagiarized it.
He asked me how did I know
what all these literary devices were
that I didn't even know
had names at the time.
Because up until this point,
because of my dyslexia,
English and writing
was always my kryptonite.
I didn't even realize that all those years
of consuming hip-hop music and culture
was actually teaching me
how to use literary techniques.
Like when Tupac said, "Picture perfect,
I paint a perfect picture,"
I would find out
that that was alliteration.
Hmm.
I wanted to try that.
"Pompous politicians pressure people
to push towards their God."
Hmm.
Now, right in that moment,
a new power was unlocked.
"We stood by street signs that were
slightly slanted in the slums of the city.
Then we gradually, geographically
graphed the graffiti on granite walls.
And this was driven from the rage
of the reaction of racism that was --"
Alright. Y'all get the point.
(Applause)
Thank you.
I would soon find out what a metaphor was.
A simile, double entendre, onomatopoeia,
end rhyme, internal rhyme and so on.
And I felt myself getting stronger
with every word and phrase
I was putting together.
Now a couple of years later,
in high school,
I would discover the world of slam poetry.
I had just recently got cut
from my basketball team,
so I had a lot of extra time on my hands
that I wasn't used to.
So what I did was
I transformed my competitive energy
from the court to the stage.
Now this was years before
I ended up going to college
and studying Chekhov and Meisner
and William Shakespeare and August Wilson.
Back then I was studying
underground battle rap kings
like Loaded Lux and Mook,
and prophets that called
themselves Def Poets.
See, those men,
they looked and sounded like me.
They sounded like
the neighborhoods I lived in.
They sounded like home.
So now, like those poets,
Lemon Andersen and Black Ice,
I started to look at people different.
Stories started coming
in and out of my mind
just from observing
the everyday world around me.
Now I can make the regular, most mundane
blue collar worker of the middle class
sound like a superhero.
Like I remember there was always
this guy on the corner
telling stories and reminiscing.
We all know this guy, right?
And all his stories would start off with,
"Y'all, I used to be nice."
(Laughter)
Most people would write him off.
But me, I saw more than a person
whose dream was deferred.
I saw a person who came alive
in those stories.
I knew that he was more than those dreams.
Whether they knew it ...
or not.
I used to be nice, yo.
Nice like Jordan fadeaway nice.
When I stepped on the court,
stars would align,
the world stopped spinning,
gravity would cease
and I appeared to jump higher.
You see, the angle of my form
was nothing less than Da Vinci's
sketch of the ideal man.
Man, I used to be nice.
I wasn't fast, but I was quick.
My defense was well equipped
and my assists were crisp.
Since birth I was chosen,
I used to part defenses like Moses.
Due to my vision, I could envision
a player's position
before they was positioned.
I was conditioned.
My no-looks were textbook,
and scouts even said I was off the hook.
Look, my crossover would put my opponent
on pause and cause the crowd to go,
Oh!
Yeah, I used to be nice.
I used to pin shots on the backboard,
never bored, and when I scored,
I transformed into something
that wasn't even human.
But who knew I would be ruined
by a guy so envious of my game,
his aim was me.
So when I heard the snap of my knee ...
everything went silent.
I no longer heard the crowd or my team.
My years of dedication
deteriorated with my dream.
So I lay there on the floor,
four minutes left, fourth quarter.
No water, just a jersey drenched in sweat.
Regrets of trying to dunk on him.
No need to ask why.
This is the hand I was dealt.
No sleeves. I couldn't cheat.
Defeat didn't taste good.
But I used to be nice, yo.
Nice like Jordan fadeaway nice.
When I stepped on the court,
the stars would align,
the world stopped spinning,
gravity would cease,
and I appeared to jump higher.
Yeah, I used to be nice.
(Applause)
Now I found myself
becoming obsessed with words
and how they sounded.
I started absorbing and paying attention
more to speech patterns
when people would speak,
when I was on a train
going through the city.
I also fell in love with jazz,
because I realized
that the style
that I was creating for myself
had elements of improvisation,
like jazz greats:
Gil Scott-Heron, Miles Davis, Thelonious.
I also went and discovered
new poets that I didn’t know.
That's when I discovered
Langston Hughes and Jean Toomer.
Now like every story,
everyone has a love interest.
And mine was Nikki Giovanni.
And I actually fell in love with her.
I found an Afrocentric descended angel ...
sitting by herself.
And she is beautiful.
Certain moments are precious, I was told.
And when you get to see
into someone's soul, you see heaven.
So if that's true, heaven is where I am.
She painted her finger across the sky
like she was painting the stars.
And the world fell silent as I listened
to the internal instrumental
that my heartbeat made.
I walked up behind her
and touched her shoulder like the wind.
And she looked at me like that familiar
image she sees in her dreams.
She is like the perfect use of assonance
in just the right amount of lines.
(Laughter)
Her pupils looked lost, and I wanted
to teach her to love what she sees.
Through pictures I have pieced together
her figure like a mosaic,
and I have her on the walls of my mind
like graffiti on the cathedrals
of the ghetto called apartments.
I sat down with her.
And I grabbed my Moon easel.
And cloud palette.
And I started to add stars
to her masterpiece.
I found an Afrocentric descended angel
that reminded me of Aphrodite,
and I wondered
what would be her aphrodisiac.
(Laughter)
She was sitting by herself.
And now I sit with her.
And she is ...
so ...
beautiful.
(Applause)
Years would pass.
And unfortunately,
I started to lose a lot of my friends
to violence and/or jail.
And it was hard for me not to feel
a sense of survivor's remorse.
So ...
it would keep me up at night
on how could I honor them.
And I realized that I can honor them
by not only telling my stories
but telling their stories as well.
So they could live on the page.
Forever.
I’m from a place
with there’s big houses and spouses.
No, I'm really from a place where
single moms commute two hours to work
in pencil skirts and nice blouses.
I'm from a place where dudes
stand in front of the bodega,
trying to hold their jeans.
I'm from a place
where there's hustlers and fiends.
Cops may intervene, some unseen.
I'm from a place where boys raise boys,
men are nonexistent and mothers are young.
So how y'all expect us to turn out?
Looking up to hustlers was our worth.
We were told that our awards were skirts.
See in the hood, fingers get contorted,
rhetoric retorted,
shots ring out by orphans.
Now RIP shirts are worn
in front of coffins
and this happens all too often
because we’re taught to do that
with no regret, rep your set.
We’re throwing up signs,
and we ain’t even deaf.
Kin to death. It's like our lives
are as long as that Bible verse:
"Jesus wept."
See, that’s why I can’t wait
till the day when my skin isn’t a novelty.
And our stories aren’t
synonymous with poverty.
Because honestly,
it’s hard to deal in modesty
when we have to deal
with this identity dichotomy.
Like, why do I have to say I'm human, too?
When DNA proves I'm deep buried in you.
We made the pyramids
so you could see a beautiful view.
We made statues with wide noses.
We were just making the truth.
So imagine someone saying it wasn't you.
And whoever did those great things
must have been much lighter than you.
But how, when you discovered the tombs,
mummy's hair was even
woven down to the root?
Truth. So if you really want
to help us young brothers out,
stop making our schools look like prisons.
Stop determining how many jails
you're going to build
off our third grade reading scores.
Scores, false cause.
Give Black boy ball and watch him score.
Give Black boy good beat,
then put him on tour.
Give Black boy big chain
because he loves the law.
The crowd just screams
because he never bores.
But then watch Black people get confused
because a couple of Black boys
are up in "Forbes."
Five mic in “Source.”
Then be biased and make him law.
Send Black boy to jail,
feed him well because he’s a Moor.
Now he’s locked down.
Now who miss his amore.
Now he gets angry. He wants more.
He screams at the top of his lungs.
His voice gets hoarse.
Because he remembers when he used to
rock polo with man on horse.
But of course, this is not
what Black boys cause.
He just stares, his look is coarse.
They made his God look nothing like him,
but made him say "Lord."
Black boy fights
in yard as guards watching us
like Ali and Foreman all over again
with the same broken jaw.
Now he saw society clips his wings,
then asks him to soar.
Now another Black boy dead,
but nobody saw.
Now another Black mother
crying in the streets, emotions raw.
Now she prays to that same God, saying,
"Why, Lord, why did you have to take
my little Black boy?
He had so much in store,
but now he's just another young,
dead Black boy."
You see, I'm from a place
where boys raise boys,
men are nonexistent and mothers are young.
So I pray for the Black boy.
(Applause)
As you see,
that little boy that has dyslexia,
that's spent half
of his educational journey
in special education and remedial classes,
that always struggled with English
and writing
eventually found his way academically
and actually started to thrive.
And that same little boy
made it to Broadway.
To the mountaintop of writing.
See, by telling stories
and being authentic to who I am,
I became the superhero
I wanted to be as a kid.
Thank you.
(Applause)